foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and actually learn to like hanging
out with each other they build great
relationships I'm John deloney joined by
Jade warshaw and we're taking your calls
on just about anything life work money
relationships all of it triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's run out to the NYC and talk
to Ben what's up Ben how we doing
Hi how are you thanks so much for taking
back home you too what up
okay uh here's my situation uh my wife
and I are in our late 30s we live in a
New York City suburb we have two
children uh nine and five and we have a
third coming in November my wife and my
wife and I have both worked at the same
place for the last eight years it's been
really convenient it's just 10 minutes
from our house they've had on-site
daycare for the kids and up until now
we've managed to be a one-car family we
have a sedan that we paid for in cash
um a job opportunity came up for myself
which is going to be a significant
income increase
um but also at the same time we had some
leadership changes at our institution
and kind of this was necessitated as
well but the new job will be a longer
commute 45 minutes to an hour and it'll
necessitate having a second vehicle now
not to mention with the third child
we're feeling a little bit cramped in
our car we've received several
um pieces you know several
recommendations from family members and
friends
um and we're looking at minivans either
the Honda Odyssey or the Toyota Sienna
my question is
um given the kind of funkiness of the
used car market and the inflated prices
does it make more sorry I'm sorry the
last part is that when I leave my
institution I'm going to be getting a 35
000 check that's after taxes
um for all of my unused sick and
vacation my question is we've got a
couple of options here we can pay for uh
we should be able to pay for
um a used Honda Odyssey with 38 000
miles or so entirely in cash we could
get a new Honda Odyssey paid most of it
in cash and have a small you know
Finance or we could do the Sienna which
is more expensive however it's also a
hybrid the mileage is almost twice as
good as the Odyssey
um so you're a guy you've done your
research like you've dug into this very
very deeply which is good yes I'm just
yes I'm just not quite sure how you do
the math here and what makes more sense
yeah you should kind of buy use with the
cash or does it make more sense to
buying
based on what you've said you're
starting to feel the pinch of what's
going on there's enough things to stress
about you've got a child coming on the
way you're switching jobs longer commute
adding debt to this equation I think is
not the move um I'm never gonna suggest
going into debt or anything especially a
car that you can get something really
really great and pay 100 cash for so
that would be my first note of advice to
you is do not go into debt uh over a car
note um and over a vehicle my second
question is do you have any other debt
Justin mortgage said that just the
mortgage okay yeah then I would and you
have three to six months of expenses set
aside
yes sir yes ma'am okay cool cool cool
um yeah I'm not going into debt over a
car when you've got cold hard cash
sitting there burning a hole in your
pocket
have you done the
um have you done the
it's not really a math equation you seem
like a guy that is really good with a
spreadsheet have you
actually driven to and from your new job
at the time that you'll be going here's
why I say that not at the time that's a
great question yeah not at the time I'll
be going but I just sort of Google Map
data it should be somewhere between 45
and an hour without you know later in
the day you know I can make it there in
you know 25 minutes without the traffic
okay I I think it's worth
um if you can sneak away just giving it
a shot and making that drive and here's
why
um there's some data that suggests the
longer the commute
really the worst all of your out your
health outcomes become over time
and I've personally just
um huberman calls it anecdata just my
experience has been
the longer my commute
um the more chaotic my life tends to be
and the more you got a third kid coming
in and you're gonna be in the car two
hours a day now and so a conversation
with your wife may include if we take
this job and ends up being amazing and
we have a third kid
do we have a conversation about 12
months 18 months that we start thinking
about are we going to move closer to
this job is this going to be a a
long-term solution Etc
um
but that doesn't solve your problem
right now but I do think it's worth a
conversation
no I think you're right on um I've been
a part this uh like I said I'm about I
would be up I would be about to lose my
job at my current sensation just because
we had a leadership change
um this I'm going from 100 000 a year to
150 I guess I'm kind of and it's also a
VP title which I didn't have before I
guess I'm kind of approaching it as this
could be like a two-year thing and then
kind of use that title change to help
find something closer to home some
remote opportunity something like that
okay are you in the University setting
by the way
I am yeah you're using the coded
language that I used for 20 years well
done man oh really yeah very good
um yeah I mean I I'm I'm with Jade I
wouldn't borrow absolutely wouldn't take
out a loan on them no not at all all
right let's run out to welcome to Miami
and talk to Jacob what's up Jacob
how you doing thank you so much for
taking my call you got it hey we're up
against the clock so hop right into your
question what's up man
awesome man so um so my question is I
have about forty thousand dollars saved
up in my bank
um I have a couple of debts
um and I would like to purchase a home
within the next six to 12 months
um my question is kind of just I don't
know if I should pay off the debts or if
I should continue to just grow my bank
accounts for that down payment
um how much debt do you have
um
so I have uh almost twelve thousand
dollars in a personal loan from a debt
consolidation that I did that's at a 23
interest yeah what else
um I have a car a brand new car I just
got I I owe about twenty three thousand
dollars Jacob what you doing what are
you doing going into more debt when you
have a debt consolidation already
second Foundation like it was
Consolidated and now I'm just paying off
that loan I know but then you went and
got into more debt with this car
yes but you didn't need a brand new a
thousand dollars in the bank you didn't
need a brand new car and you certainly
didn't need to go into debt for I'm
calling you out on it because the reason
I'm calling you out on is because I
don't want you to end up in a situation
where you're having to do debt
consolidation again and what we've
learned from this and I want all the
viewers to listen up what we've learned
from this situation is debt
consolidation does not break the habit
of taking on debt and we've just now
seen it here it just moves it around and
makes you think you've done something so
Jacob to answer your question I would
take the money that you have I would pay
off your debt what's your income
um I'm bringing about 80 to 90 000 uh I
have a full-time job that brings in
about 50 to 60 and then I have a couple
of side jobs yeah let's pay off that I
do let's take that 40 000 let's pay off
this debt today I want you to keep a
thousand dollars aside whatever's left
add that with your three to six months
of income and I don't want you taking
out a mortgage until you've got the
correct amount down payment saved
anywhere between five to twenty percent
where the uh where the payments no more
than 25 of your take-home pay you're
broke you can't afford a house pay your
debts off Jacob this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
so I'm holding an article here from
cnn.com written by Nicole Goodkind
the headline is U.S debt Rises to 33
trillion as Government shutdown Looms
article begins as the U.S debt passes 33
trillion in a government shutdown looms
Wall Street feels defensive the shutdown
could sour sentiment and deal a blow to
an economy already dealing with high gas
prices Auto worker strikes and elevated
inflation with some saying it could even
increase the possibility of a recession
let me be real clear if the government
shuts down
you're going to see catastrophic losses
across the board because the world
depends on one thing the United States
to pay their bills
and we have a group of
grown-ups sitting in a sandbox throwing
sand at each other and they're going to
set off a bomb
in in the name of or a Instagram post or
in the name of a sound bite for their
next campaign and they're gonna
what a catastrophic mess so Jade when I
see U.S debt rise to 33 trillion
um this is me just being honest and
vulnerable with my friend here in front
of I don't know a couple of dozen
million people
it sets off an anxiety in me does it
like it it it it it will if I if I if I
dwell on it it will make it hard to
breathe because
I'm doing what I can in my home and I'm
looking at the world I got a
seven-year-old little girl and a 13 year
old boy I'm looking at the world they're
inheriting inheriting
and it makes it hard for me to wrap my
head around the world they're going to
be living in because a bunch of adults
act like such immature bratty children
and have created such a quagmire and I
see this number going up and up and no
matter who you vote for whatever side
you vote for
everybody's lying to you so they can get
in and do what they want to do
help me help me 33 trillion dollars is a
lot of money I mean an interesting I I
can't do anything about it I mean when I
see things like this I I'll be honest
I'm almost on that exact opposite
spectrum of you I don't that much of but
that much attention to it I mean I see
it and I go that sucks that's bad
um but you can only control the
controllables and for most of us that's
looking at our own house like these are
the times a lot of times we're like zoom
out zoom out this is the time where I'm
like zoom in like zoom in and don't look
at the giant statistic don't look at the
big scary monster zoom in and go okay
what's my part in this am I
participating in this do I have a say in
this can I control this and what can I
control do you know what I'm saying and
I think I get a lot of peace out of that
of going okay I I know where my power
lies and I know what control I have and
that over there has zero to do with it
yeah because I can't even think about it
right I can't do anything about that all
I can do is make sure I'm not
contributing to the problem make sure
you know because all of this is
connected it's all connected and as
American people we what we do affects
the economy that affects National
economies that affects all of this U.S
debt Global economies and so Play Your
Part yeah like shoot your shot and play
your hand the right way and for most of
us that looks like handling your
financial household as well as you
possibly can being a good Steward of the
money that you have because here's the
thing no one can point the finger at the
government and no one can point the
finger at red or blue if in their own
house it's a hot mess right and we
already know that most Americans that's
that's what it is so instead of getting
so like and I'm not yelling at you but I
know you got your stuff together no but
it's good because it's it's I'm allowing
myself to be distracted yeah right I'm
allowing myself to be distracted and to
be frustrated at things that I really
can't do I get a vote every two years
and I get a vote every four years and
that's that's the game that I'm in and
that's the game I get to play and so I
get to make my vote
um
so this reminds me of a call Dave and I
took right after covid um maybe it was
2021 early 2021
um and it was from a school teacher in
New York who I mean the lockdowns were
very severe and we're teaching in
elementary school I don't remember
exactly what she was teaching but an
elementary school teacher on on zoom and
she just looked at her student loan debt
which I think was a hundred thousand
bucks she owned a bunch of money owed a
bunch of money
and she just said I'm done
and she worked like a maniac she got up
before the crack of dawn and drove and
delivered food she got she taught all
day she worked until lately late yeah
and she just burned through and paid it
all off like she just said I'm I cannot
do this and so I want to challenge
people I love what you're saying like
control you can control we say that all
the time so here's me doing this in real
time I feel this
my body feels 33 trillion dollars and
the fear I have for my little girl and
my little boy mm-hmm
also
I also feel the fear of our elected
officials acting like freaking children
I'm gonna shut you down I'm gonna shut
I'm gonna take the my ball and go home
instead of getting in a room and saying
hey I don't care who wins because if you
win and I lose we all lose can we help
solve this problem for this country
please so instead of that
um I'm gonna feel those feelings they're
real sure and then I'm gonna go do the
next right thing which is make sure I
don't owe anybody any money make sure my
neighbors are know that I'm a resource
for them yes they need some support and
vice versa and I'm gonna keep my eyes
open for other people I can serve and
love and I'm gonna turn the news off and
um
I mean it's that I'm gonna double down
on relationships because what else can
you do right it's that cliche that we
hear it's on t-shirts some mugs it's you
being the change that you want to see
that's it you cannot point fingers and
say oh look at them they're doing this
these are terrible people these are
horrible are you a good boss are you a
good you know are you a great person to
work with are you a great spouse are you
handling your money like that's what we
have to do is look back and go okay I
can't just keep throwing stones I've
gotta do the best that I can do for me
in my house and set an example the more
you put in the world light pushes out
dark that's all I'm saying yeah
and remember well I don't get political
it's funny you're striving not to get
political I'm striving not to get
spiritual because I I go straight I go
straight to the top on stuff like this
I'm like oh what is your hope truly in
but that's a conversation for another
day that is true all right I'm gonna yes
we're gonna get ourselves canceled
talking about politics and Jesus
let's go to Orlando where they've got it
all together and talk to the Great and
Powerful Jared what's up Jared
how you doing guys hey I agree with both
of you awesome which one's more right
one of us is a little bit writer Jared
what's up man
your frustration more than the other one
between baby steps three and baby step
four and hoping you guys can get me in
the right direction on that yes um
so uh we are a single income family
um and uh over the last year we moved
across the state switched jobs uh sold
the house bought a house a lot of
craziness
um
so buying a house moving in we round up
you know we plan for fixing some things
and we had some cash set aside from the
equity of the last house to roll into
that so that all handled itself fine and
then you know there were a few more
things than we thought as it goes so we
went a little further into the emergency
fund than my plan had been with
switching jobs and everything
so right now we're sitting on about five
months of EX of four walls expenses in
reserve and I'm working with a smart
investor Pro and he's telling me like uh
you know you're in a very high demand
field and kids I work in technology like
you really don't need six months because
he's trying to get me to invest and I'm
like I hear you dude but you're working
on
you know management fees for me here so
you you're not entirely an impartial
opinion here so I'm just I'm just trying
to figure out like
is it supposed to be for walls is it
supposed to be yeah your regular
expenses is supposed to be a month of
income that you're like what's the
actual metric and what do I really need
because I know single income it's for
sure six months yeah Jared you're you're
asking all the right questions and thank
you for asking that because I know
plenty of people looking at our YouTube
or listening to this on podcasts or
wondering the same thing and we really
do it based off of basic expenses not
necessarily all the way down to four
walls but if you were to lose your job
lose your income how much money do you
need to keep your household ticking I'm
not talking about getting your nails
done I'm talking about keeping your
household ticking so for most people you
know you can go through and see what
that's going to be in your case you've
got a single income I'm going with six
months of expenses forget what that
advisor's saying you're right he's
trying to get more money quicker
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45 five percent off that's
blinds.com rules and restrictions May
apply
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw we're taking your
calls on just about everything triple
825-5225 let's go out to Dan Dan in St
Louis Missouri I don't know what I'm
spelling people's names I was out too
late last night what's up Dan
dude we're rocking on to the Breaking
Dawn my brother what's up
uh the question I got for you I've been
divorced for about you know about seven
years and uh my current girlfriend I've
been dating her since
um I've been divorced uh for about seven
years
uh I just kind of curious she's you know
I guess traditional and I am too in a
sense but
she you know had been pushed to get
married
um I don't have anything against
marriage or anything
um even though I've been divorced
but I guess kind of my main issue with
it is you know I just um
I became you know wealthy here you know
recently uh probably the last you know
five years uh by I had my own company
that I run and I'm very successful at it
and
um it just it just makes me saying
because you know if that's a smart move
I I've been through the court system
it's not fair it's really not fair for
anybody you know they're just
bloodthirsty you know tyrants
and I don't really ever want to be in
that situation ever again
um you know I know you can do prenups
and whatnot but in the end those things
are you know like toilet paper in a
sense I mean I mean they're not but but
here let's let's
what is it about your girlfriend of
seven years
that you don't trust
well it's not that I don't trust it is
it is it is you don't trust her
because you built a life for almost a
decade with her yet over here
your languages I've become wealthy
so you've created a life
of your own inside of this seven year
relationship
why don't you trust her
is it because you got burned bad with
your ex
and you're dragging that old
relationship well actually I did no okay
I didn't get burned at all through my ex
I actually got burned from my parents
okay and it's still kind of ongoing in a
sense but
um it's just it you know in a sense it's
it I I don't know I just I I have this
life that you know I want to travel the
world and do these things and and I'll
be able to do that and it's not the
responsibility both Jade and I have
traveled the world with our spouses
and it's been infinitely better than
traveling around by ourselves yeah
because when I went I wasn't like Sam
this is what I can afford to do sorry
you can't come because you can't afford
to do that
I wasn't like I'm gonna ride on this
plane you ride on that plane and I'm
gonna stay in this hotel because I can
afford it and you stay in that hotel uh
that's you know a couple Stars smaller
and I get to eat at this restaurant
because I can afford it but you've got
to order the side salad do you see how
kind of crazy that sounds
yeah I understand and I've been
wrestling with that for years you know
but it's like it's also a thing too
where it's like you know I've risked
stuff and I've worked my ass off to get
you know where I'm at and I don't want
to give that up and like okay stop right
there though stop right there challenge
that thought Give It Up to who
is the woman you've been with for seven
years the kind of person that will take
you for everything she'll do you wrong
she'll cheat on you she'll steal from
you and take half of your stuff and take
off is that who she is no she no that's
no okay then why are you carrying that
story around because I can't wait to get
wealthy with my wife as my partner
I can't wait
because I've met a bunch of miserable
wealthy single dudes
and I understand
I've been taught that you know I've
worked so hard and so long and it's in
addition but she's been with you she's
been with you for for all five of those
years well can I can I pull another
thread on this
um well the first question I have is how
wealthy are you
well I'm 41.
um you know I don't know I'd say
probably like 1.2 1.5 okay good someone
in there yeah the thing is but a lot of
my wealth is in my company because
everything I have I own of course and
you know I own my house and all my cars
I don't know I hate loans I absolutely
hate loans and so excuse to ever get
along and that's the that's the that's
the threat I want to pull something
about what you're saying about you you
believe the opposite is true about her
because you keep saying how much of a
hard worker you are and how much you
hate debt that's making me believe that
you that's why I want to know more about
the fiance because you're not married
yet so you don't have to do anything yet
but do you if you can be honest I don't
know if she listens to the show but is
there a part of you that's like hey I
feel like she's
not a hard worker I feel like she
doesn't have the same views as me on
dead and money like can I pull that
thread a little bit
no she's actually a hard worker she
really is but it but in life to be
successful you have to work harder on
yourself than on your job is what Jim
Rome would say and I'm a fluent listener
of him I never thought I'd be ever taken
advice from a dead man before but the
guy was was amazing I listened to a lot
of this stuff you know uh I think you
need to I think you need to break up
with your girlfriend today
you you don't think that you guys are on
the same level Setter free
because I I know I know you're not going
to and I know I'm just a knucklehead on
a podcast I get that on the radio
but you don't trust her
you don't have a you want to have this
this life that you're creating alone
yet have her as a hood ornament
you you say I try to do that I I think I
know I think we're able to build you
know as a team but you you keep saying I
I've built this money I've done this
stuff this is mine I don't want anyone
to take it from me foreign
and you've been with the same woman for
seven years and and let me add to that
what I would be listening for let me
juxtapose it with what I would be
listening for on a healthy side and John
you're you're the guy who knows this so
you tell me if I hear someone talk about
their soon-to-be spouse
I also I don't hear them say well I do
this I do this I hear them say oh man
and my husband he's so good at holding
me accountable and I'm not great with
this but he's so good with that and even
though I'm you know this is one of the
things I'm good at but he adds so much
to the equation like you're constantly
balancing each other out I haven't heard
you say one good thing about her you
haven't said or one thing that she
brings to the table or how she's an
asset like I'm looking for that sort of
language so well I mean she is you know
the other thing too is is you know I
have you know two girls that are almost
grown and she has you know two boys that
are almost grown here's the the here's
the equation that I'm really stuck in
I'm just having contemplations about
really the whole thing is my business
hey I need to get a commercial you know
shop okay I need I need a big place
because I've been running this out of my
house and I I've exploded my house I
have it my house is my work okay and
it's just it's too much so I have to
sell and I need to move forward with
this and I've been kind of wanting to
move to you know like either Tennessee
or Texas or something because that's I
just you know got a calling to go to
either one of those two places I really
love Tennessee been there many times
yeah yeah get to the get to get to what
you're talking about you just so you
know she doesn't really want to move
okay that's it right there that's it
right there that's it right there unless
he's married unless she's married which
I understand I I totally understand you
don't want to marry her you don't want
to be already married and you're not you
should not marry her just to get you to
come with her
you should not marry her for that no no
I understand that but it it's dragging
the kids and you know resetting
everything and and getting a bigger you
know like a you know you got six people
girlfriend if you're listening go it's
time to leave it's time to go on guy is
not yeah let her go here's why
[Music]
you've been with the same person for
seven years you can say what you want
but behavior is a language you don't
trust her you don't want to build a
future with her you're annoyed at how
big the house is going to get you're
gonna have to get a shop and she might
not be called to Texas and she's too
traditional all these things and I
believe you probably didn't get burned
hard and it's it's the worst and your
parents are still a mess you got kids
involved I get it let her go don't drag
her behind the car of your life we'll be
right back
foreign
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show and if you
want us to tell you to break up with
your girlfriend give us a call to play
825-5225
um so Jay we're just out of the lobby
um and if you come visit us here at
Ramsey headquarters in Franklin just
south of Nashville
um you come get some free cookies and
coffee and drinks or whatever and
there's a bookstore here and we'll take
photos and sign your sign your books and
stuff
um
she didn't give us permission so he
won't say her name but somebody told us
a cool story out there yeah she
was in I heard you guys talking on the
radio about it being important to get
your income up and most of us it's just
a few tweaks that we can make to really
bring in more money and she took that
advice to heart and in a very short
period of time more than double their
income and is making like a hundred a
hundred thousand a year right did I get
that right yeah okay and so me and John
are sitting there like that is
incredible like your boss slapped her a
high five and I said to John I said that
what's amazing about her is that she was
able to do that but what bothers me is
most of us in society could never tell
the people in our Circle something like
that without them getting very weird
right like how many people I mean think
about it if you're listening in your car
right now you're watching on YouTube
think about the people count on your
hands that if you doubled your income
tomorrow you could call them up and be
like dude let me tell you what just
happened
think about the people that you could
tell in your circle hey I just became a
millionaire today
think about the people in your circle
that you could tell and you know they
would be happy if you said I paid off my
house today
for most of us
we don't have that we don't have it we
have a culture addicted to entering
rooms butt cracks first and here's what
I mean by that hey how was your weekend
Jade it was fine dude the kids were dead
my husband Sam was uh and because if I
say hey how's your weekend and you're
like
freaking awesome it was awesome like a
husband helped out he was great the kids
and we had a great weekend yeah I'm
Gonna Roll my eyes and go oh must be
nice must be nice dude I wish my my wish
my wife would be oh I hate that must
yeah it must be nice hey dude guess what
I just did some reimagining in my home
business and within a month I've doubled
my income
screaming together it's like yes oh that
must be nice I had to do this project or
better yet John what if we were the type
of people that if somebody says Hey I
just doubled my income what if we were
the type of people that said really
how'd you do that how'd you do that how
did you do that because I would love to
do that yes that's a whole other level
of maturity of just like personal
acceptance to be able to look at
somebody else congratulate them first
ask how they did it next when you look
out over the skyline in New York City
and you think
look how tall those buildings are
how'd they get so tall I want to build a
tall building I want to be just like
them yeah when you get to that level of
I just want to be just like them you'll
find it's much easier to knock a
building down
than it is to build one and it's so much
it's so much faster it's so much easier
to dismiss somebody's Joy
then recognize the Gap in your own life
and say I I'm not there I want to get
there in my marriage I want to get there
with my finances I want to get there
with my relationship with my daughter
yeah
how do we get there let's do that let's
do that and not even making an Roi how
do I how do I how do I but just good for
you good for you good for you I walked
out of the building the other day and uh
one of my buddies walked up he was like
I mean it had nothing to do with the
conversation he's like yeah we paid off
our house the other day and I could have
turned flips I was so excited like I I
was ready to do cartwheels like you know
like let's Frolic in the field and like
jump up you know like that scene in
Rocky where they're on the beach and
they're like high-fiving like that was
how I was feeling in my mind I was like
this is amazing good for you and that is
the type of culture that you should be
creating with your friend group with
your family members like because here's
the thing if you can talk about that
kind of stuff you can talk about the
other stuff too No One's Gonna if you
can't tell someone the good stuff then
tell your friend they're not your friend
you shouldn't just have to you shouldn't
be in relationships that all you can do
is complain together that's exactly
right because then your community is
formed by who y'all hate together
and then you get our current political
system which is has nothing to do with
solving a problem yes it has everything
to do with tearing your idea down yes
there is no hey we just need to figure
this out and so if it's all about
complaining complaining complaining it's
all about oh we hate them and it's them
and it's those folks instead of dude
let's do something amazing yeah I I
remember there's no room for Solutions
either no well the only solution is you
can't have a solution then we can't
complain anymore together that's right
and then you got two football teams
playing defense and the ball never moves
man because I'm trying not yeah anyway I
I remember like and I'll get choked up
so I gotta be careful I remember
um
book my last book goes number one I had
some a run of speaking gigs I had just a
run and I come from a family without a
lot and my wife comes from a family
without a lot four hardworking parents
that did like work their butts off yeah
didn't have a lot
and it was just a wild year and Dave is
super super generous to us and I called
one of my friends back home and I said I
don't even want to tell this but here's
what our year was last year and dude he
oh his name is Todd he cheered on the
phone Todd and he's like dude and he
said I know how hard you've been working
yes and and they made fun of me for
years because he was the one that made
the most and the other other one of my
buddies made the middle and I was always
the guy with all the degrees that was
working at the University making less
than him
and do they cheered and cheered and it
was this like dude and then it was like
you're and then it ended with I'm never
buying dinner with you again but fair
enough he's my butt of course he's gonna
rag on me right but it was that moment
that had somebody to call and just say
hey can I just celebrate this with you
yes and he's like oh I would be my
life's on yes and when my mom one day
gets sick I'm gonna call him too and
he's gonna weep with me that's what
friendship is right that's what
connection is I love that um I have a
couple of friends that I can tell him
whatever's going on and it's that same
feeling and for anybody listening I I
want to challenge you not to shrink back
because when you're in relationships
where you feel like you can't come into
the room like you said if you have to
come in butt crack versus a problem if
you can't come into the room as you
fully are and feel celebrated and want
to be celebrated then it's like why
would you shrink back around those
people and some of us we feel it with
our family right you can't you can't
process yeah you came from a certain
family and it's like oh you think you're
really something now you know you're
getting ahead now you know you don't
come to the family reunion like you used
to you know it's that kind of feeling
and we immediately feel like we have to
and my friend gets on me all the time
for this she's like Jade you're
constantly like dumbing like bringing it
down and be like oh that's not that big
of a deal oh well you know I
stop doing that stop you don't have to
dumb it down for those folks if they
don't get it they'll be all right they
can go kick rocks they'll be okay you do
not have to dump your success down you
do not have to dumb down the things that
give you Joy that you've worked hard
John like you said you don't have to do
that start fostering that if they get
uncomfortable that's on them I think
that we should come in the room and face
first face first not in a way that's
going to stick it to folks yeah not like
an arrogant idiot no not like an
arrogant but in a way that's like hey
like this is bringing everybody up and
this is like this is just what we do
this is who we are like I love that I
love it I love it hey and by the way if
you're like we always want this to be a
community where you can share your wins
it's not bragging it's not bragging so
we want to hear from you guys leave it
in the chats leave it in the comments uh
put it on our social media tell us what
you're doing tell us how you doubled
your income tell us how your business is
popping off tell us how you're
succeeding and we will always slap you a
high five it reminds me um when James
and I and Kelly kicked off my show
several years ago in the basement right
we're down in a basement studio and I
was so new to this whole thing people
would call and say hey my mom's got
cancer I don't want to do hey my wife
cheated on me on what to do hit my kids
sick
so often at the beginning I would ask
the question why are you calling me like
I'm a stranger dude and they would say
to a person
man I got nobody I got nobody to tell
the hard stuff
and as we're having this conversation I
wonder how many more people
don't have anybody tell the good stuff
to yeah okay I had a good week I had my
first week where I wasn't the depression
wasn't so heavy and I I got out and went
for a walk every day this week yeah and
I got nobody to call yeah right this is
the first week since I finished chemo
that I can go for a walk around my
neighborhood and my guts don't feel like
they're gonna come out I'm about like I
got nobody call and so I we I talk a lot
about loneliness we talk a lot about
loneliness having somebody to call in an
emergency this conversation Jay just and
I'm changing my mind in real time I
think that the conversation yeah you
gotta have somebody to call in an
emergency your body needs to know you're
safe but there's something to be said
for do you have somebody that you can
celebrate your life with the little all
of that bitty wins and everybody
listening to the show the big tough guys
in the big trucks The Single Moms with
three kids and everybody in between
you're worth having people in your life
you can celebrate with that's right go
make it happen the Ramsey Show we'll see
you soon
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
all right
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create amazing relationships
I'm John deloney joined by Jade warshall
and we're taking your calls on money and
life and work and mental health and
emotional health and a partridge in a
pear tree anything you got we got an
opinion on give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jenna
is just looking alive in there taking
your calls she's ready let's go out to
Flagstaff AZ and talk to Garrett what is
up Garrett
hey guys how's it going thank you so
much for having me on the show thanks
man we're having a party in here what's
up
awesome awesome well just regarding your
last section of like the whole if you uh
doubled your income which I recently
have I'm super glad to say that I have a
bunch of people that was able to reach
out to so shout out to my parents just
there and they're listening somewhere
out there but good job man that's
awesome I'll look it right to the point
not good job you good job parents good
job your parents that's awesome that's
great yeah shout out shout out Mom and
Dad thank you so much uh all right well
I'm 19 and I really want to be
financially free by 30 and I've recently
started a new job where I'm working
about part-time 20 hours a week and I'm
making somewhere between 40 and 50 000
for the year
um but I'm also a full-time student up
at NAU and I just wanted um to kind of
get you guys advice on maybe dropping
out and working full-time
um and just kind of hear what you guys
had to think about that what are you
studying
uh construction management I'm I'm not
super passionate about it I mean I chose
it because it's one of the quickest
degrees to
um right out of college you start making
about eighty thousand dollars a year
it's a terrible reason to get a degree
terrible reasons yeah but I mean I also
had a full ride scholarship to NAU so
I'm basically going yes that's a great
reason to get a degree that's fantastic
yeah yes no for sure for sure and I mean
that's kind of I don't I know if I do
drop out or take a semester off or
anything I'm gonna lose that scholarship
that I'm currently working on what's
your what's your job right now like you
said you've doubled your income you're
doing pretty well what are you doing
yeah so I'm a server
um I've been serving for a couple um a
year and a half now and I started at
this new job that is really popping and
I make a ton of money there and I know
that I'll probably start making even
more money once I become more familiar
with the job a server like at a
restaurant
yeah it's called fat olives so shout out
found all of you guys should come check
it out full of the shout outs I love it
um no for sure so Jade you and I've
never talked about this so I'm
interested to hear we may give him
conflicting advice what do you think ah
you know my thought is okay the server
thing here's where what what's easy to
do whatever the thing that's making the
money it becomes your new favorite thing
right
um so I want to make sure that being a
server when you look up because you said
Hey by the time I'm 30 I want to be
financially free do you see yourself
being a server at fat olives when you're
30 that's really the question free
server at fat olives that's the question
you have to ask yourself and if the
answer is no then it's like okay what do
I see myself doing when I'm 30 and
figure out what that is and then we're
kind of reverse engineering and going
backwards and saying okay what has to be
true today so that that can be true when
I'm 30.
okay yeah um so I mean my main goal I'm
I'm really good with money I've been
able to save money my whole life I have
two paid off uh cars right now and about
6 000 in the bank
um so I know that with this amount of
money I want to start getting into real
estate and be able to have that work for
me Airbnb as well hold on hold on your
server at fat olives
yes sir don't say it like it's a bad
thing you're talking about like real
estate and when somebody says I'm really
good with money and you're 19 and you're
going to college and you're a server and
you're like I got two paid off cars I'm
gonna say you haven't borrowed money
but are you good with money why do you
need a second paid off car at 19.
um well the thing is I I'm at Flagstaff
so I just bought a car I'm actually
downsizing it was much cheaper but I
needed a four-wheel drive and I'm
currently trying to sell off okay so off
my other car but but they are both paid
off here's here's my two this this is
dude this is just me and you can
um this you know this advice might be
worth what what you pay for it okay
um two important things I want you to
keep in mind
um and I'll get this is a lesson from
the great Tony Robbins when you make us
when you make a goal I want to be
financially free by 30.
that's like saying I want to lose a
hundred pounds
and he has this great exercise where he
calls somebody up on stage and says I'm
gonna put 50 million dollars into escrow
if you think you can lose 60 pounds by
tomorrow
and they say and if you do it
um I'll give you the money like I
couldn't do that and he goes yeah you
could you could call a surgeon I'll call
a surgeon and we'll remove one of your
legs for 50 million dollars
and now it's like oh I can do that when
you have a goal that is and it is
untethered to anything other than I want
that finish line by this date what
happens is you start like Jade said you
chase firecrackers and you chase the
next bright light in front of you and
then you start cutting corners
because what you're not talking about is
building a peaceful life you don't want
to have a great marriage and have kids
that love you and want to be in your
presence at 30. you're not talking about
building an amazing career in a business
at 30 you've just giving yourself this
arbitrary date in this arbitrary finish
line that is financially free
and so my challenge to you is not
thinking about a Finish Line
think about the life you want to build
by the time you're 30.
what is that going to look like
and I will tell you I've never met a 30
year old
I haven't yet I'm sure they exist
they came back and said I had a full
ride scholarship
and I quit because I was making so much
money waiting tables
I'm so glad I did that I haven't met
that person I have met many people who
wish they had not taken out a bunch of
student loans
but if you were my son if you were my
brother if you were my brother's son and
you came to me and asked this question I
would say dude keep waiting tables keep
making that money and take that free
college education learn everything you
can about construction management if
you're going to Real Estate you're going
to learn about plumbing and Foundations
and begin to use that education not just
for the certificate but for the wider
conversation you're going to learn make
friends with contractors make friends
with Landscape Architects make friends
with the whole system
and then you walk away with a free
four-year degree that's worth its weight
in gold because you didn't pay anything
for it and then you head out and keep
serving at fat olives and by the way
don't get into real estate your first
move into real estate is buying a home
for you that you can afford right and
you're understanding okay this is what
it looks like this is maintenance this
is all those things that's how you're
buying a home and you're doing that
later on you know your graduated college
and that's when you're doing that I
don't want you jumping the gun because
again really to John's point you could
get yourself the biggest problem you'll
face right now is trying to go too fast
and make bad decisions because you're
trying to go too fast you got plenty of
time you're 19. so let me back out real
quick and let you just in on something
you're 19 you have a full ride
scholarship you're not getting a degree
in something stupid you're getting a
degree that you could have some
certifications and go out and make a
great living and help people have homes
you could actually help people with your
degree and you are not scared of hard
work and you have no debt and you are
saving you are so far ahead very good
any 19 year olds
[Music]
I say stay in school finish that degree
and keep serving it the fat olives fat
olives you're welcome for the shout out
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
hey everybody I've got a brand new book
coming out called building a non-anxious
life
you pre-order today you'll get 75 bucks
in free bonus items that's us trying to
encourage you gently nudge you to pick
it up before it releases in a few weeks
on October 3rd
everybody's dealing with burnout or
stress
chronic stress anxiety we talked about
earlier I'm anxious about what the
Knuckleheads in Washington and their
sandbox throwing toys at each other no I
don't want to play I don't want to play
it's making me bananas listen can't do
anything about them but we can
make intentional choices every day to
create a non-anxious home in a
non-anxious life in a non-anxious
marriage in an unanxious business and so
in this book you're going to learn
effective techniques to identify and
respond to Life's challenges and
ultimately transform your life it's 20
bucks go to ramseysolutions.com and
listen please mark your calendars
October 5th right here at the building
in the event center we are having a
blowout book release party I'm gonna
stay I'll stay all night sign
everybody's books take photos with
everybody we're going to have some wild
adventures if you can imagine a party
that a event if you will um I'll be
speaking we'll have some special guests
show up that they let me just kind of
off the rails this is a deloni planned
event it's going to be equal to that
level of chaos what sorts of things will
transpire here John I'm curious all
talks um we'll have some my wife's gonna
make a a surprise appearance we'll have
some uh musician show it's just gonna be
a little bit off the rails here's my
goal I want people Jade to get in their
cars and look at the person they came
with and say the words
what just happened that was amazing what
just happened yes exactly that's the
goal that's the goal so October 5th it's
35 bucks that comes with a book and of
course they'll sign up we'll hang out
all night
um if you're going to be in Nashville
please please come up we got people
flying in from all over the country
um I would love to have you October 5th
go to ramseysolutions.com or go to John
deloney.com and you can get your ticket
there oh I'm gonna get me I think I'll
get me a ticket oh you don't have to pay
you know a guy walk you up get your hook
up Sam though Sam's got paid Sam's gotta
pay dang it all right let's go to uh uh
neighborly question of the day today's
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when something in your home breaks
neighborly is the name to remember
and with the neighborly Done Right
promise you know you'll get great
service from their local network from
their network of local home service
providers go to neighborly.com today all
right today's question comes from Kelly
in Texas she says how do you celebrate
wins while working through your debt
snowball well I love that question
um and I'm gonna say John that there's a
two-part answer to this because
it depends on how long you're gonna be
in baby step two because if you're
working through a debt snowball that
just means for the people who may not
know new listeners it means that you're
paying off your debt you're listening
I'm smallest to largest in order to do
that
um all of your debt except the house so
that's what this person is doing that's
called baby step two and
um on average most people are you know
they're doing that between it's taken in
between
um 18 to 24 months in order to get that
done
and
there is the exception to that rule like
my husband and I took us seven and a
half years so we know that there's a
spectrum of time that it can take uh to
do your debt snowball depending on how
much debt you have so that kind of
informs my two sides of this equation if
you're average and you're doing this
thing in a year and a half you know to
two years
um
this the ways I would celebrate would be
really small because I want to keep my
budget as Slim as possible so that I can
keep the momentum going of actually
paying the debt off so for me if you're
in that average category a win would be
like hey we're watching we're we're
renting Back to the Future and we're
watching it and we're ordering a pizza
like that's that's a great celebration
on a Friday night when you're in baby
step two it's not
a big deal it's not throwing you off
track it's not costing hundreds of
dollars
um conversely if you're on the other
side of the equation and you're you know
this you're going to be in this thing
for four years five years that sort of
thing there then there's kind of a
mental health component in this in this
equation if I'm being honest yeah
because you can't live scorched Earth
mentality for four and five and six and
seven years that just does something to
your soul it's never intended for that
to be your way of life it's a temporary
sacrifice right for a long-term gain
it's not supposed to be like that all
the time so when you're in that sort of
situation then you do uh need to build
in bigger milestones and you do this
ahead of time you don't just be like you
know what I need a break because when
you do that you'll never come back so
you need to go into it saying okay when
you know when the debt goes from here to
here we go do this and when the debt
goes from here to here we go do this set
it up ahead of time and when you're uh
when you have that longer period of time
you can do bigger things to sacrifice or
bigger things to celebrate like
um if you've been side hustling for four
years you're like I hate this side
hustle I'm gonna quit I'm gonna quit
side hustle for a little while and give
myself a break like that's a great way
to celebrate and then I'm gonna quit for
two months and I'm gonna pick it up
again if you've been driving Uber Eats
for from 6 a.m to 8 P.M 8 A.M until you
go to work that two hours back feels
like you just won the lottery oh man it
doesn't take much right no that's right
I think here's an important thing
psychologically and there's some
psychological research behind this
it is important however small if it's a
you light some candles in your living
room and you all have a dance yeah yeah
you both make chocolate chip cookies
together and try to recreate that scene
from Ghost I don't know what weird
things y'all do people do at their house
you have to Market you got to mark it
yeah even if it's going outside and just
screaming as loud as you can until
you're red in the face yeah you spray
each other with a water hose I don't
know everything's sound like an 80s
Montage do something to Mark the moment
we just paid off a 700 credit card we
just paid off a 70 000 student loan
Markham because you're gonna lean back
on those moments that you marching
that's why graduation ceremonies are
important funerals are important
weddings are important because they are
markers they are moments that we all go
remember that day that we said never
again or that day that we won right so
however big or small but it's not an
excuse to yeah oh we paid off a 400
thing let's go out for a steak dinner no
you're on to the next exactly very good
great big great question all right let's
run out to Winter Haven Florida and talk
to Alden what's up Alden how are we
doing
Alden you there hello hey man yeah I
can't hear you guys all right hey we're
up against the clock brother so uh go
ahead and get right to your question
what's up
all right so um pretty much me and my
wife has built up a pretty amount of a
good amount of debt
um and how much be specific through it
how much debt you got
um so for Consumer Debt we have roughly
about 55 000
um my wife has a student loan of 7K
um and then we have a vehicle which is
about 45. okay so is it the 7K plus the
45 or is it the 55 plus the 7K plus the
45.
yes all those together okay all those
together so really you're over a hundred
thousand
correct yeah okay
um so net income we make about uh
monthly we make about like 43 50 a month
okay
yeah so right now I'm I'm the only one
primarily at work um me and my wife just
recently had twins okay about a year ago
so uh she hasn't fully gone back to work
so right now everything is kind of so
what's your question brother yeah
um so I'm just trying to see uh you know
the best way to kind of work through
that debt okay
um my screen says
that you're considering bankruptcy is
that true
yes so earlier in the year we did kind
of go through that process
um you know because I you don't kind of
go through it yeah
no no we didn't we just looked into it
you looked into it all right correct
yeah so here's what I think you I think
right now you guys are in a season your
wife has just had babies uh she's not
working you're bringing in a little more
than four thousand bucks a month and
you're seeing over a hundred thousand
dollars of debt and you're like oh crap
right this is a lot right yeah
um this is temporary
so I want to start by saying that like
sometimes in a moment can be like oh
this is going to last forever we're
never gonna get out but it's not it's
temporary your life's Gonna Change I'm
gonna hold him over because this is an
important call
um brother Alvin stay on the line man
and um we're gonna go to break and then
we come back we're gonna come back to
you
um okay because this is important I know
you got a lot going on and Jade's got
some wisdom it's gonna give you some
peace in your household with those
um new babies and your lovely wife okay
all right thank you so hang on brother
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw we are talking to
Alvin who lives in Florida is recently
married has two twin babies they're
about a year old and has 55 thousand
dollars in Consumer Debt has a forty
five thousand dollar car loan has a
small student loan
and it's just feeling like he can't
breathe does that sound right brother
yeah right definitely cool man
all right so we were talking right
before the break
um go ahead Jade see how so yeah so
let's let's look at this you were
considering bankruptcy of course John
and I are going to do everything we can
to talk you out of that
um because in this case I truly if I
thought it were the answer and the best
answer I would tell you and I do not
think it's even close to being the right
answer I think that you're uh closer to
a light at the end of the tunnel here
than what you realize number one I mean
you're making a little more than fifty
thousand dollars a year you got 107 000
of debt right now your wife is not
working because she just had two babies
but if she were working she'd probably
be bringing in around 50 as well and you
already know you can live off of one
salary so you would have been debt free
in one year so like I just want to put
that in your brain as you're closer to
the Finish Line than you realize okay
now
I want to look at this car uh forty five
thousand dollars for a car is this your
only is this are you a single car family
or do you have another car that's paid
for a secondary car
um so right now that's our only vehicle
um
so that's the only car we have yeah so
we upgraded once we got the the babies
oh I see so you owe you owe forty five
thousand on it what's it worth if you
were to sell it
um probably like 30 because we just got
in about a year ago too so so you and
you bought it brand new
yeah and so you taking a 15 000 did you
roll negative equity into it
because that's a big hit fifty thousand
dollars
no
um because we traded in a car but uh
yeah I think we added about like it was
the negative equity was about like six
thousand okay so that feels right yeah
okay so uh fifteen thousand dollars
um what's your credit like
credit
um is not good because we've while we're
doing the process of when we looked into
bankruptcy we did speak to a lawyer and
they did advise that you know we don't
make any payments or minimum payments so
we took a couple hits
um when we didn't make those payments
okay so we just yeah we're recently just
getting back are you back caught up
um not yet not yet
yeah okay so
fifteen thousand dollars is a big hit
because technically it would be 20 to
technically be like 23 because I'd want
you to if you were able to with your
credit if you're able to get a loan for
the difference I'd also want you to
include enough to get a cash car in this
case I just don't think I would because
you're still gonna it's not gonna make a
big enough Dent to truly truly matter
for you
um
if you weren't so far upside down I
might suggest it and you still could I'm
not saying not to but you've got to
decide how worth it is how worth it it's
going to be to you
um in order to take that hit do you see
what I'm saying
right yeah what do you what do you do
for a living man
so I do a home security installation
how secure is that job
um so it fluctuates it's
um you know there's pretty much as you
get base paced off of um like install so
there's days you can get three or four
installs and then there's days or you
know you have nothing so what do you do
on nothing else
nothing days I try to uh recently
started trying to do a couple like
ubereats door dashing yeah
um just to try to get back because
that's what I got right now so I want
you I want you to keep doing that I want
you to keep doing that I want to make
sure that every day you're working at at
least eight hours whether it's your
full-time job or doing ubereats and then
I want you to kick it up a notch and go
okay now I'm doing my extra work and I'm
doing extra side Hustle
because right now this is a season that
you're gonna work a lot when does your
wife due or she already had the babies
she already had the baby she already had
the babies it's been a year yep so
they're a year old yeah yeah okay Alden
I if I'm you
um
I would sit down and tell my wife I'm so
scared I can't breathe
and I am
gonna spend 12 months
stepping up and we're gonna I'm gonna
miss some big milestones in these little
one-year-olds lives but we're playing a
long game with him and I want you to
look your wife in the eye and say I'm
playing a long game with you too
and both of y'all had a picture of what
life was going to look like with these
two beautiful twins what's going to look
like and that picture is still very very
real it's tangible Jade and I have both
dug ourselves out of bigger holes than
you have okay
and we both know the sacrifice it takes
it's gonna suck
yeah but I want you to do the math I
know you're you my brother are worth it
your wife is worth it those babies are
worth it so what does that mean you have
a very inconsistent job
I want you to do the math on what would
happen if you walked in and became an
assistant manager at a McDonald's making
18.50 an hour and you did ubereats from
5 a.m until 8 A.M and then after you got
off McDonald's you delivered pizzas or
you drove lift until midnight I I want
you making a hundred thousand dollars
and here's the deal we hear the stories
every day every day and those people are
so tired they can hardly move their face
but they dig themselves out of these
wild crazy holes
[Music]
not forever it's for one year all right
you're yeah you're going hard in the
paint for one year
one year do you have enough
um
ah do you have enough courage to go work
at McDonald's
to go work at Walmart oh yeah well yeah
crazy thing I used to be a department
manager over there so there you go I
have the courage all right okay great
and hey I just I just made that that I
just made that job up
I just know that I'm looking at these
service jobs that are 15 an hour sixteen
dollars an hour 20 an hour that they
cannot fill
and I know it sounds cooler like no I do
security installs but you and I both
know that's a sketchy schedule it's
feaster fam and it's good and right now
you don't have time for feaster famine
you have you need all feast all the time
right that might mean I'm going to stock
um be a nighttime stalker at Walmart I'm
gonna do the night shift stock boxes and
then I'm gonna get off and I'm gonna
drive until my eyelids start to close on
me then I'm gonna go to bed and sleep
and do it all over again I'm gonna miss
my family for 12 months
for all human history men have been
leaving their families to go do what
they had to do for a season and this is
that season for you and on the other
side dude
what's he looking at and that's the
thing like we get so caught up on this
side and the side's painful but on the
other side there's peace on the other
side here's what happens on the other
side John you're not thinking about all
the things you did it's over it's over
it's over and done and all you're
looking at is man this is these are the
spoils of my hard work this is the fruit
of all that we did all that we
sacrificed and life is good man you know
what the spoils are for this guy for you
Alden it's you rolling out of bed and
your wife hands you a cup of coffee and
these two knuckle-headed three-year-olds
come barging all over you I love it you
got nowhere to be
your work doesn't start for another hour
and a half you can even get a workout in
if you want to if you want to be crazy
but everything changes there's a bunch
of snack crumbs everywhere everywhere
crumbs in your sheets from these kids
and you just say get back up here anyway
it doesn't matter because you can
breathe man yeah I love that and then
your wife get to go on a date again
because y'all have money in the account
every Everything Changes Everything
Everything Changes hang on the line
here's what we're gonna give you I'm
Gonna Give You FPU Financial Peace
University I want you and your wife to
watch these lessons these videos these
can be date nights because you ain't
going out on dates anymore for a while
also I'm gonna give you every dollar for
you and your wife to use it's gonna link
to your bank we're going to stay away
from bankruptcy and you're all going to
practice for the first time talking
about money sharing the same account
you're going to lean into this thing
together and this is the best tool on
the market for that and it's going to
help you all plan your get out of debt
tools it's going to take care of
everything
um stay on the line here and we're gonna
hook you up call us anytime you need
anything we got you I'm proud of you
Alden
this is one of those moments that I
husband and wife say this is we're done
yeah we're done and you'll be stronger
for it and you and Sam had that me and
Sheila had that look both of us are
smiling right now he's gonna look back
and it's gonna be the greatest blessing
of his life that they went through this
I'm just saying
gosh dude and then after that run for
Congress because they need somebody like
you there this is the Ramsey Show we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how we owe 33 trillion dollars and
they're having fights about the dress
code if you can't even wrap your head
around
and you're wondering how did we get in
this mess how can we teach people to
handle their money the right way the way
Dave's been teaching people for 30 years
here's a simple doesn't cost you
anything
way to help
just hit the like or subscribe button
send an episode to your friends and say
hey this is a great segment they were
talking about you you're thinking about
bankruptcy don't do it here's some ideas
um you just had babies this is this
one's for you
if you will send it out if you'll like
it subscribe it you hear you hear people
on YouTube say that all the time
it's not a vanity metric as much as it
is a way to kick this thing up into the
algorithm so it puts it in front of more
people more of the time
and it gets this information out to a
country that desperately desperately
needs it so leave a leave a five star
review if you have a negative review
leave it attention George camel share it
with a friend subscribe do all the
things we're super grateful and don't do
that to George camel he is we're best
friends all right let's go out to Salt
Lake City Utah and talk to Sophie what
up Sophie
hello
um so it's good to be on the show my
husband and I started listening a couple
weeks ago
um we have been pretty stressed on our
finances lately no contention but you
know it's stressing us out a bit and
um we started looking into the first
couple baby steps we we have the the
thousand dollars great so that's good
um
but we're really like there's not a ton
of wiggle room in our budget every month
and we're looking at the stop all
Investments and we're wondering if HSA
is counted in that Investment Group
would you stop HSA yeah contributions
yeah so that's super I'm glad you
brought that up So for anybody listening
baby step two is is the step where
you're paying off all of your debt
except your mortgage right and in order
to do that quickly you want as much
margin as you can get your hands on and
one of the ways to do that obviously you
can get your income up you can get your
expenses down but a big way like just a
low lift way is to pause investing so
right now uh Sophie how much are you
guys investing like whether it be in
your HSA 401ks
so we stopped our 401k last week when
listening to this awesome
um but our HSA
it's probably about
500 a month going into Yes Man heck yeah
I'm stopping that it's temporary
and that's the thing I want you to hear
and anybody else listening when we're
telling you to do this it's a temporary
pause because we know that it's far more
important for you to get that money back
into your your hands every month so that
you can get this debt paid off so
quickly you'll it's going to make your
head spin and then you're going to have
so much more time and so much more money
to put towards investing I mean
percentage-wise I'm not sure what you
were at before you started the baby
steps but I guarantee you'll be able to
put a higher percentage when you're
finished with baby step two and it's
gonna make up for any difference in time
does that make sense
yes okay before before you get off go
ahead Sophie go ahead
um as far as HSA goes I was planning
like I was thinking that was going to be
your answer that was my guess but I have
about
dollars in medical bills that need to be
paid would you because we had a baby
this year I was gonna actually ask that
question so to Jade so if I know I've
gotta have my kids braces tightened
three times
that's that's less about investing in
HSA that's just putting money aside that
you know you're going to spend and it's
just a little bit of a loophole right
yeah it's a loophole I mean if you're if
you just want to filter it through the
HSA so that you're getting the tax
advantage that's totally fine I mean I
that's what Sam and I did
um I didn't have a situation to where
like my job was all you know uh
automatically putting money in an HSA I
would just say oh this this medical debt
is 700 I'd filter it through there then
when tax time came I was able to show
hey this was a medical expense it went
through the HSA that's fine if you want
that tax savings I'm not mad at that but
the idea of
um just come because yeah compounding it
there and not only that but I still want
to make sure that you're filtering all
this through the the debt snowball and I
want to make sure you're doing them from
smallest to largest even with the
medical debt because with medical day
here's the thing let me just be honest
in some cases with medical debt time is
your friend because it's like hey I've
had this debt for a minute while I've
been doing my debt snowballed you guys
want to make a deal and they're going to
make a deal every hospital is going to
make a deal and you're going to pay less
than what the bill was so
there's kind of a silver lining on that
yeah I I like that I like the idea of
being intentional and I'm I'm with you
if we're gonna if we if you know you've
got medical expenses coming and you want
to just funnel it through that yeah
that's great that's smart that's savvy
so good I love it all right let's run
out to Detroit Rock City and talk to
chase what up Chase
hello hey man what's up
um hi I'm thanks for having me on of
course what's up man
um my wife and I are new to the baby
sets and we wasn't paycheck to paycheck
and we're struggling to even get the
thousand dollars for the emergency fund
with the bills that we have and to pay
the minimums on the bills that we have I
just want to know where do we start what
do we do and like what are the order of
the things like of importance that we
need to make sure to get paid first and
go from there yeah that's good
um look let me first of all say I get it
because when Sam and I started our
journey we didn't have enough money to
to pay all the debts like there was not
enough money coming in and that for us
was the big thing it's like okay like
what we got to get more income coming in
so my question to you right now is what
is your income
um
I make about the ranges of dynamic hours
I worked about eight fifty two thousand
dollars a week uh she makes I mean if
she pay her she works out of daycare so
half of that goes to the daycare cost so
we have twin girls that we just had last
year oh great
um so which month
200 a week after the daycare costs
um
around 48 around 4 800 a month between
the two of you yeah in the middle range
depending on how many hours I work each
week and what determines how many hours
you work each week
um the jobs that we have I'm uh
I do service work for a petroleum
company so the amount of jobs that we
have in that day depending on how long
it takes I usually work around 48 to 55
hours a week 48 to 55. okay
um we're about to double it yeah
um
I want there to be more stability in
what you're earning I don't want it to
be like oh on this down week or on this
up week I want every week to be an up
week and I want you to be able to
control that so whether that's tacking
on a side hustle or that's doing the
same type of job in a different scenario
where you're having more of a steady
income I'd love to look into those
options
um how much debt are we talking about
uh including the mortgage or not
including the mortgage not including the
mortgage so baby step two is your all of
your debt except the mortgage
we're looking at around 71 000. okay 71
000. all right that's you know we we
gotta we got a little something ahead of
us so with this baby step one
um
help me understand what's keeping you
from getting the thousand dollars
because I can tell you statistically
most people are able to get the thousand
dollars saved within 30 days and that's
not just working their job they're going
they're looking in their garage they're
selling stuff they're you know they're
getting crazy in order to get that
thousand dollars and I think that might
be you might be lacking some intensity
in that area
so week to week you know we we go
through we we don't have like a monthly
budget so we try we go paycheck the
paycheck so we try to figure out where
all the dollars are going to go from
week to week
okay so that's that mine ranges a little
bit and then Harris is usually steady
but
um so there's our first there's our
first issue I I want you guys to do a
monthly budget and we're going to give
you every dollar before this call is
over because on every dollar you can
plan out each paycheck when you're gonna
get it and they've got a feature in
there that's called paycheck planning so
you can decide ahead of time okay the
water bill comes out on this day and the
mortgage comes out on this day and the
daycare thing comes out on this day and
you can plan all of that ahead of time
so that you can see for the month
because sometimes you need a broader
picture not just a weekly picture so you
can see really what's going on with the
money and I think that's going to help
you a lot so monthly budget and we do a
different budget every month because
every month is slightly different right
it's not a set it and forget it kind of
thing and then the second thing is
getting that income and getting more
going into the debt snowball right so
you can get this thousand dollars saved
quick and then we're attacking that debt
it's a process that's right it's not
going to be quick let me just say and
you're gonna have to work and we're work
and work and work and work but there's
no more going home when there's no jobs
you're going to ubereats you're going
you're going to the office you're going
to figure something else out no such
thing as a down week this is the Ramsey
Show we'll be back soon
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
what up what up live from the
headquarters of Ramsey Solutions it's
the Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth do work they love and learn
how to be in the same room together
have great relationships I'm John
deloney joined by my friend Jade warshaw
and we're taking your calls on work
money life relationships mental health
whatever you got going on we're here to
help triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five squat two
Walla Walla Walla Walla Washington and
talk to Sarah what's up Sarah
hey what's up
um well I've got a kind of interesting
question
um interest rates are really bad right
now I know that I understand that um we
have a situation with our neighbors that
has just become increasingly toxic and
um we've had to like call the police on
them and a lot a lot of bad things have
gone down I won't go into all the
details but um I still would like to
move because I feel like um this is a
bad situation for me and my family and I
feel like we can afford to move but my
husband is just it's killing him to try
to sell this house with the interest
rates what would you say because the in
what's your interest rate right now
it's like seven percent some something
around there yeah okay and the houses
are expensive in this area yeah so the
house you're living in now how long have
you been living there
I've been living here for eight years
and you've got seven percent it's not
less
um right now we're at like a 2.5 or 15
years oh okay right he doesn't want to
sell yeah that's what I wanted to verify
when you said it was seven I was like
wait what
um yeah look that's the that's the
quandary that's the conundrum that so
many Americans are facing is like okay
am I just gonna live in this house
forever because I didn't intend to but
at the same time I don't want to take
you know a five percent hit in hit on my
interest rate so
I the way I like to frame this in my
brain is
you don't let the market interest rates
all these other uh factors that we can't
control determine when it's time to buy
a house what determines truly when it's
time for you to buy a house when it's
time for you to move is a if you can't
afford to
and be if you want to and they have to
go together if you can afford to that's
thing one that's got to be in place and
then you've got like do I do we want to
move is this the best for us and for the
picture that we have of our family so
those are the things that go together in
this case it sounds like they're both
aligning but it sounds like your husband
is a little bit more like looking at the
numbers he's more of the math guy right
and he's a little bit of a scrooge yeah
but um
give me some insight into what's going
on because
if I had a bad neighbor situation where
I had to call the police to keep my
family safe
and my wife came to me in tears and said
I've got to get out of here
I don't care what the we're renting I
know right I'm out
so either the neighbors aren't that bad
are they loud are they sitting in like a
one of those little kiddie pools that
they got at Walmart and they're drinking
too much are they selling like drugs and
yeah they're violent yeah
oh there's a combo there's the loud
music but also um the wife has become
increasingly possible to my husband
screaming swearing at him and just for
like whenever she can and then their
kids have been this historically really
unkind to my kids but then now they're
just taken to like always flipping them
off and then it got really bad um like
Rockstar to another house and there was
messages written on our driveway saying
move out and all this kind of stuff and
so we called the cops the cops told us
to put up cameras and after we did
um the wife of this and this other house
published online that were perverts
trying to watch them in their pool and
um I really feel like I'm on like Mori
right now like this is this is good
radio
you are not the father and then we told
him to get off my lawn
yeah dude this is like this is like
taking us back to Middle School like
elementary school so right yeah I I
would
I don't know why is it your house earned
about this
he is he is um we're caught we had the
cops come over the cops saw our footage
of our cameras and thought we're not
looking at them at all we're just
looking at our own property because
um they're the ones who are throwing the
Rocks they've done it many times and we
just need camera proof now and anyways
so um
now he is upset we've had the cops tell
them not to do it not to trespass but at
the same time like they're still
flipping us off this is
okay so it's twofold here number one you
have a picture of your house of this
life you want to have
and it's where all the adults are
rational and all the kids get along and
that's not your world right right right
so
you have to make peace with either a I'm
gonna teach my kids there's just some
those kids are growing up in a tough
situation and so we are going to not
give them space in our souls we're gonna
head out
and you're not gonna play with them
they're rude and if they flip you off
that's that's rude and we're gonna move
on or you can walk away and the it's
it's that old saying not by your hand
but in your lap
you didn't cause this and yet here it is
and when you take responsibility for
your own life it always always comes
with consequences always I refuse to be
abused anymore okay well now you're a
single mom and you're gonna have to
figure it out yeah I refuse to be in
debt anymore okay tough guy now you got
to work three jobs for the next two
years it always comes with something so
if you say I am sick of my kids getting
flipped off which you should be by the
way I'm sick of my husband next thing
she's going to accuse my husband of
something and it's gonna be a mess
totally get it and you're gonna have to
sacrifice four percent on an interest
rate somewhere or rent for a year let's
talk about these dollars and cents
because I want to know a little bit more
of whether if you do choose to move if
you truly can buy a house or if you
would be renting because I definitely
don't want you to think you can afford
to
move and buy another house if you truly
can't so do you have any other debt okay
um no we we really have tried to do the
um Dave Ramsey principals and we don't
have any other debt
um yeah we have a house is worth 440 000
we have 140 left on it so we do have a
big chunk to put down on another house
you don't have to have to find a buyer
in this market
okay and do you have an idea of where
you would go have you started pricing
out things are you just making a lateral
move or are you trying to well you've
been looking for houses for months
haven't you
yeah yeah that it fell through anyways
she's like I don't want to talk about
that
um yeah I doubt yeah sorry so as long as
you you know obviously you and your
husband have to get on the same page
about this and you know the way we teach
I don't want you going into a 30-year
mortgage I want you on a 15-year fixed
is that what you were looking at
um we're gonna do the 30 and then change
come on Sarah do you know why we suggest
a 15-year fixed
right so so you can build wealth and
yeah I don't want you in debt for 30
years in 30 years you're gonna be I'm
gonna guess 60.
you don't want to be paying a mortgage
that long I want you out of debt so you
can build wealth so 15-year fix where
the payments no more than 25 of your
take-home pay and family put a sign in
the yard
y'all are spending months worrying about
how long it's going to take to sell the
house you could have had a sign in the
yard 60 days ago you'd be halfway home
put put the house up for sale and see
what happens
and then be ready to rock and roll
Make Your Move we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show George
and the every dollar team are hosting
free live virtual trainings this month
to get to help you get clarity with your
money
you'll learn how to find more margin in
your finances spend guilt-free and make
a budget that works for you the next one
is happening September 26th at 12 30
Eastern 11 30 a.m Central spots are
limited so register for free at
everydollar.com
budgeting everydollar.com budgeting and
don't forget October 5th
the building and non-anxious Life
release party Extravaganza they've let
me plan the whole thing and it's going
to be wheels off it's here at the Ramsey
Event Center
um tickets are 35 bucks and that
includes a book that and I'll stay all
night sign them we'll hang out with
everybody it'll take every photo you
want to take and well not the weird ones
and we are going to have a blast lots of
surprises lots of fun maybe even don't
button will make a uh an appearance
interesting probably not but that would
be red we need to set that up Ben that'd
be very cool so go to John delaney.com
get a ticket come visit come and visit
come hang out we're gonna have a blast
let's roll out to Portland and talk to
Duke what's up Duke
hey what's going on we're getting it man
what about you
no I'm just hanging in there um hey so I
have a question about uh I'm getting a
new job
um that requires me to move uh to
Oklahoma for about six months God why
did you do that
well it's a good job it's for air
traffic control I know but it's Oklahoma
Southern it's it's basically Southern
Canada if you're growing up no no no I'm
playing Oklahoma's awesome so uh so okay
so you're moving to Oklahoma air traffic
controller to keep all the planes in the
air we're grateful for you and what's up
so I I'd have to go there for training
and then after that uh I'm gonna be
located somewhere for probably about
three years for to finish the training
so I'm gonna be renting for a while uh I
own a house right now
and I'm just trying to figure out what
would be the best course if I should
rent it out or if I should sell it uh
because I I got a really good interest
rate and like uh if I were to sell it uh
it's already worth like 100 Grand more
than I paid for it yeah I just don't
know
if it were me if I were in your shoes
and I were moving from Oregon to
Oklahoma and then having kind of like
this training period trial period for
you know a couple of years of my life I
would definitely sell the house because
a
you don't live there anymore and renting
it while your States and states away
like half a country away
um that's going to be so stressful
you're gonna have to hire Property
Management that's a thing in and of
itself I I mean you're going to be
living in a state where
you're just constantly wondering what's
going on with this property so I will be
alone a long distance uh you know long
distance landlord man yeah that sounds
terrible to me I'll take 100 Grand I
mean look how my lucky stars and be
happy let's take it let's take a page
out of Dave Ramsey Playbook Dave Ramsey
would say if you lived in Oklahoma would
you off the top of your head go you know
what I want a rental property let me buy
one in in Portland Oregon
that's a great place for me you would
never do that right
so it's this it's this idea of hey I've
already put money and time and energy
into this property it's sometimes hard
for us to cut ties with that when really
it's like hey that season is over go
ahead and cut ties you don't have to
keep dumping more money and time and
energy into it just because you have for
so long you can cut ties and you can
move on in the major I made you a
hundred thousand dollars yeah that's
great well done dude drop that in a high
yield savings account do you have any
other debt
um just two cars uh well it's only like
ten thousand total okay so pay off your
debt and dump the rest in a high yield
savings account and and sit on it for a
couple years that's what I would do and
when you go to Oklahoma don't buy a
truck and jack it up
or a Honda Civic and lower it really low
and get one of those Mufflers that
sounds like a bumblebee trap inside of a
dryer vent don't do that either those
may be the two cars that's so funny I'm
gonna get so much hate from Oklahoma I
was gonna say is that what you think the
oklahomians do no that's what I know
Jade Oklahoma no I I when you grow up in
Texas they just teach you
to love the the states on your Texas
east or west
and across that River all right let's go
out to Colombia and talk to the Great
and Powerful Adam what's up Adam
um hello hello what's going on what's up
man
uh I just wasn't ready um so I gotcha I
love this show this show is great what's
up I was very uh I uh so I just got off
the phone with my mom a couple hours ago
um me and my fiance were saving them for
a wedding I just paid off about 30 000
in debt yeah yeah yesterday or a couple
days ago because I sold my truck got uh
some traveling expenses paid from from
my uh transition out of the military
okay and now I uh we're talking about
car insurance for the new beater I just
got with my mom and it was like three
four it was like 365 for six months and
I'm like oh that's awesome it's a really
good deal and she was like okay but you
have to pay the six months right now and
I'm like oh well I don't have the money
right now I'm fitting into this budget
um next month we can budget it and get
it and she was like oh why don't you
just put it on our credit card
and I said well we canceled all of our
credit cards like I canceled all of them
and then she went crazy and I mean
mainly because she loves me and she only
cares about me but like I've never seen
my mom get so mad about something before
and somebody cancel my credit cards and
then one thing led to another and I was
like oh well we don't really need credit
because I plan on getting the 15-year
fixed rate and then she's like oh and
then yeah I went because she's a real
estate broker and so she went crazy
about how by the time I save up a down
payment well
houses were going crazy yeah so
basically I just my question is
is I I know the answer to my own
question but I'm not really sure
it feels wrong because I'm like defining
my mom and like doing my own thing how
old are you yeah 23 23. you veteran four
you did four years yeah are you still in
uh I did five and a half six I'm in the
reserves now okay
um so I just want to make sure I'm doing
the right thing by not having any open
lines of credit and canceling everything
here's the thing you're here's what I
want to tell you and John's going to
really hit this you're grown
you don't have to do what we tell you on
the radio and you don't have to do what
your mom tells you you're a grown man
and you get to make decisions so since
you called and asked for your for Our
advice we'll give you our advice and
then you're gonna go and decide what you
want to do with that I think that it's a
great idea to take debt off the table
and not utilize that now I also don't
want you driving around for a month
without car insurance so I want to make
sure you are fully insured in the
correct way all right so that's thing
one thing two is no I don't think you
should go into debt so that you can pay
ahead
thing three is I think you need to trust
yourself and Trust the information that
you're Gathering and
trusted and understand it enough to
where you can stand up for it it's not a
thing of I'm doing this because they
said to or I'm doing this because my mom
said to so that's what I want to
challenge you with and then John you're
you're about you're about to get married
you're a U.S veteran
your mommy does not need to be buying
your car insurance for you go to
xander.com and buy your own car
insurance like a grown man okay
yeah so uh so it is me buying my own car
insurance she just went and did the
quote for me and I already do have
insurance through Geico okay but I'm not
trying to break the law no dude it's all
good but um if you can learn what I'm
about to tell you right now and you just
Lodge this away in your back pocket
forever
um it's going to give you a leg up on
life
just because
it doesn't feel good doesn't mean it's
not the right move
there may be a season where you have to
go have a really uncomfortable
conversation with your kids teacher or
the kids principal it's not going to
feel good you don't want to have that
conversation you're going to feel all
like am I am I doing the right thing yes
you go do it
just because your mom has chosen to do
with money a certain way her whole life
and by the way you probably would not be
doing what you're doing if that had
worked for her or if she had had a home
that was full of peace
you're choosing to do something
different because you grew out of that
system and like you said your mom's a
good woman she's doing the best she
could you just got some new information
and some better information on how to
build a peaceful non-exist house right
so I'm not gonna drink the haterade I'm
not gonna get mad at my mom and my mom
doesn't get a vote on how me and my
future wife spend our money do our
finances
um
you're on the right path man just
because it feels weird
so choose guilt over resentment every
time guilt oversim you feel guilty about
defying your mom but I don't want to
resent my mom by getting a bunch of
credit cards you're the man I'm proud of
it
[Music]
[Applause]
hey welcome back to the Ramsey Show and
on the debt free stage we've got Jamie
and John from Dayton Ohio what up hey
thanks for having us of course y'all
doing well oh great yes doing good you
don't look nervous at all
hey I assure you I don't I don't know
what I'm doing either so y'all are cute
all right so you're on the debt free
stage how much you pay off we paid about
twenty four thousand dollars 24 Grand
how long did it take five months yes
how much were you making and right
around a hundred thousand the whole time
love it love it love it so what kind of
debt was this 24 000. it was the rest of
our mortgage
yes weird people oh yeah oh yeah hey
hey Grand if we take out taxes in Dayton
24 Grand in five months y'all got after
it uh we sold some stuff yeah you did
yes yes
a lot of um old Pokemon cards from 20
years ago video games yeah
James gas James just fletched his pearls
wow he has Pokemon like tattooed across
his chest he can hardly breathe in there
right now who's Pokemon cards they were
mine they were mine I was a nerd wow I
mean I still am but yeah they were worth
24 000 that's what's got me yeah so the
most expensive card we had was an
autographed Lord of the Rings card and
it sold for 1900 on eBay that was the
most expensive yes but most of them sold
between 99 cents to 300 or so yeah wow
yes so I don't even know what's
happening right now this is incredible
this is incredible so I I want to know
more I mean you had 24 000 left on your
mortgage what happened five months ago
that made you be like you know what
let's go yeah well we um started the we
um started the review plan in like 2017
we bought the house in 2010. and we had
been paying off like maybe an extra 80
or so per month just slowly trying to
get it down and it was probably
September of last year when I was
listening to the show and within like a
one week span I heard George tell two
different people like you can't be doing
all these different things at once like
you're trying to pay off debt you're
trying to like
um invest in things and that was mostly
for baby step two but I was like you
know maybe we should be doing the same
thing because we were trying to save up
for vacation pay off the house and save
it for a water heater doing all the
things so one night I came up to John I
said can we just like do that ourselves
and like put all of that money and
energy toward paying off the house
instead so we started in September and
we like I said sold all the trading
cards and video games and we took some
money out of our non-emergency savings
whatever other savings we had we ended
up paying off ten thousand dollars in
one of those months let's go and then
finally in February the end of February
we paid off the whole house wow all
right John so I'm assuming you'll met
when you're most students at Hogwarts is
that right stop no no no no no no okay
so how did you end up on this journey
uh well we bought the house in 2010 and
uh we came to the marriage debt free uh
that was something that you know we kind
of pride ourselves on and just kind of
slowly and steady the entire time
and so this has just been a way I'll do
live oh yeah oh yeah pretty much yes wow
so what does it feel I mean how many
months have passed have you had one
month where you had so you haven't made
the payment uh yeah we we paid it off in
February so it's been a few months we it
hasn't it doesn't feel any different um
I mean my income had dropped a little
bit after that so we weren't able to
save you know more money than what the
mortgage payment was but I mean the
income is coming back up again so now
we're starting to be able to save more
money to give more money so now it's
feeling incredible now so that's the
financial side of the feelings I want to
know what does it feel like to get in
your bed
no payments I mean come on I mean it
feels really really good it does it is
very very freeing for sure and it still
doesn't feel real yeah yeah every now
and then I go in the backyard I'm like
we don't have a mortgage anymore just
gotta pinch yourself you know yes I
could just see you in the backyard with
like a sword point to the sky and be
like I'm debt free that's amazing man
yes all right so um there's a very
practical side to this
um
you've got this beautiful little girl
over here
and
she's grown up in a house that's been
largely debt free so you often had that
stress that almost every family in
America has
how much of a role did looking over and
seeing her and saying we want to be able
to do this vacation we want to be able
to say yes to stuff we don't want to be
moms and dads have to say no to
everything or all that she play in
inspiring hell to get this thing paid
off I mean we we definitely knew from
the start we wanted her to go to college
debt free so we you know started putting
money aside toward her college and just
knowing that she didn't have to grow up
or you know grow up go to go to school
having to go through all the the debt
and everything to be able to be
financially free to do what she wants to
do you know I speak to
sorry Jade I'm fascinated by Jamie and
John they're amazing they are amazing
and most people don't do life I mean
life like that they enter in the
marriage with no debt they just say oh
yeah we'll just compare our house off
and they just up and do it yes so I may
know a guy that pathologically collects
books and guitars and you know James and
George camel are obsessed with their
Pokemon cards right
what do you tell people who have these
collections sitting in a box in the back
of their house that has that has obvious
value
and it's hard to part with it what do
you tell what have you missed since you
don't have those cards in the back room
I mean I'm enjoying all the space that I
have now that's for sure I I did have a
hoarder mentality for a while but trying
to you know declutter my life declutter
the house it's like I don't really need
all those things anymore where we're
having fun doing what we have and if
we're not using it anymore then why keep
it around you know yeah John did you
sacrifice anything
not not so much just kind of the uh the
monthly income just kind of trying to
put that away and uh yep
spend that as wise as we can see that's
awesome so the mentality behind it you
guys you guys have your mind right right
yes you both have your head on straight
John's like you know I'm willing to do
what I have to do with my income you're
like I'm willing to do what I have to do
with things that are personal to me that
I value and really at the end of the day
that's what you need in order to have
success so I'm proud of you guys that's
excellent slow and steady wins the race
every single time that's right
um Allison do you want to join them up
there
no no
that's very cool man I I love that my
kids would have run up and be like yeah
look at me look at me that's awesome
um so
give one piece of wisdom to somebody a
couple who is trying to like is looking
at each other listening to this the same
as you heard George say they're watching
this call like 24 000 five months we
could do that we could do that I'm not
selling my fill in the blank give One
Word of Wisdom I'm here for both of you
well definitely the the budget meetings
definitely helped I'm not a money person
not a numbers person and I didn't really
like doing the meetings at first but
being able to get together once a month
and look at where we are where we're
going being on the same page on
everything that has definitely helped
along the way
and just kind of being on the same page
with each other being able to have that
communication yes we can do this no we
can't the budget is really actually very
freeing because there are times when
it's like she wants to go out and spend
money on this I want to go out and spend
money on that and we can do that because
we plan for it it's in the budget yeah
now that you don't have a mortgage you
can do anything and shout out to every
dollar in the every dollar team for
helping us out with that too come on
so we have John and Jamie and the
incredible Allison off to the side here
from Dayton Ohio
they've lived a debt-free life except
for this mortgage it's been hanging
around since 2010 five months ago they
looked at each other and said I'm in you
in and they high-fived and they did like
is there like a Pokemon thing is there a
thing that they do Super Saiyan gotta
catch them all gotta catch you gotta
catch them wrong things they caught them
all
and then sold some stuff
saved all the money paid off twenty four
thousand dollars in five months and they
are debt free they don't even have a
mortgage count it down let's hear a debt
free scream all right three two one
yeah
[Applause]
awesome and hey we're gonna give you a
copy of baby steps millionaires that's
your next that's the next Finish Line in
your journey there and we're gonna give
you a copy of Total Money Makeover that
you can give to a friend or a family
member or just your neighbor and says
why are you smiling and laughing all the
time because we don't owe anybody
anything you what and you can hand them
that book and that'll be our gift to you
and they've got the FPU in there too oh
that's right that's right yeah
um
Jade it never gets old it's my favorite
part I know it's great it's my favorite
part of the job watching people be free
yes I love it hey we'll be right back
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw today's scripture
of the day is Ecclesiastes 7 8. the end
of something is better than its
beginning
patience is better than arrogance
Dr Jordan Peterson says the successful
Among Us delay gratification and bargain
with the future
you're gonna have this stuck in my head
all day and I can't finish that line
let's go to Baltimore and talk to Brad
what's up Brad
yeah hello thanks for having me thanks
for calling in man what's up
okay so I'm I'm 25 years old you
graduated college
um
I have I got an accident but was it my
fault I have about I got a 2020 Toyota
Camry's 28k and I have about 26 left in
student loans
um the reason I got the car it wasn't
just to show off is because
um I need the car to get to work I'm a
field engineer for a vagina contractor
make about 81k a year my question is if
I sell the car what when I I finished
baby stop one when I be um and why
basically still owe on the car or should
I wait to
because I'd say about 1500 a month
because I live at home and I'm single
one I'm going to be smarter to save um
much money saved like five to six months
and then try to get a used car then sell
the car and then pay the balance or
should I sell the car you get a used car
and continue making payments to it so
let me just make sure I understand your
numbers did you say you owe 28 000 on
the car
no that's my student loan I was 26 on a
current I was 23 but it's a total of 26.
okay I mean 2600 a month you owe 23 on
the car and 26 on student loans
yes okay uh you owe 23 on the car but
what's the car worth
26. okay
um
yeah I the fact that you can make money
on this if you sell it is good so I what
I would do is I would stack up maybe two
or three more thousand dollars from your
income
in the next yeah in the next month or
two and I would sell this car and I
would put the 3000 with your other 3 000
and I buy a six thousand dollar cash car
and then I would use your income all the
extra income that you can get your hands
on and I would pay off this student loan
in a year
and I was thinking about two things I
can do it and I was thinking about
getting a second job the only reason why
is because the project I'm on it's like
it's it's a Time Comfort it's a time
constant it looks like it doesn't work
so I'm like trying to find other means
of like making money but if you believe
I can make a knee I'm gonna try my best
to make it New Year it's just you and
you live at home and you make eighty
thousand dollars a year you have no in
you have no expenses your two major
expenses the two major expenses are home
and home mortgage and by the way if
you're a renter that's the most variable
expense you don't have that then under
that for most people is the car payment
you're getting rid of that
Top Ramen and Chef Boyardee only cost
that so much so I'm trying to understand
what is it that you're spending your
money on you know I'm just joking but
you see what I'm saying no I know I know
I know because I I do say about 15
sometimes 2K that's if I don't like
buying me food during that two weeks but
what else are you spending all the other
thousands is it a girl
no no that's right it's not a girl is it
is it yeah Pokemon cards
it's because I'm actually I'm invested
in a business I know it's in my business
out loud yeah you're spending stupid
money and you know what you're ashamed
of yourself aren't you yeah that's why
you left it out come on come on Brad
what are you investing in
no it's it's an abdominal investment so
it's like it's currently being made at
the moment
um bro you are being played out by your
friends stop it to I want you to stop it
instantly you are the hey tell me if I'm
wrong you're the guy you're the buddy
who made it
you made it yeah
your other buddies didn't and you went
you went and busted it you graduated
college and you landed an 80 000 degree
which if you're 23 is a million dollars
yeah you have an 80 000 job and you're
living at home so you got no bills yeah
and then your buddy's like bro I got
this idea for an app and you don't want
to leave your brothers behind and you're
like I'll help you out tell me if I'm
right
immediately I need you to get out of
this app and immediately tell them tell
them guys I'm I was like I was stupid
I'm dumb and here's the thing it's not
in writing right y'all don't have
anything in writing
no yeah get out run get out while you
still can you don't want to lose any
more money in this and here here's the
thing it's not that you don't you know
like you don't have to be mean to your
friend and be like I don't think you
know this is not gonna make it it's just
about you using your money in a in a
smarter way and investing in the right
in the right things at the right time
and um okay risking it for the biscuit
in this case is not bread some of my
best friends on planet Earth guys that
would take a bullet for me that I've
known for almost every day of my life I
love them like a brother and I would
never invest a dime with them I wouldn't
hire them I wouldn't hire them no no and
I love them all right those two things
can happen at the same time okay
they're just not the working kind of
guys can you tell us how much how much
were you putting towards this per month
honesty about
14.35 okay I paid up to 23k so far oh so
I'm gonna just think of rice your
student loan would have been gone bro
town and Motown you'd be free you'd be
free please please
yeah I I beg of you to stop investing in
that although I still have questions
because still there's a lot of thousands
of dollars that's missing out of this uh
I'm just wondering where the other 1500
is going but Paul you put 23 000 into
this app
it was an investment
I know but what's yeah basically a
social media app it's a social media app
for like Christians are basically
helping a lot of fun
what are you helping Christians do for
twenty three thousand dollars Mingle
[Laughter]
what do you hope that Christians do
uh basically come together and
come to coffee shops and let's meet up
yeah basically okay cool
um let's stop investing in it I think
that she said that's so nice all right
that's nice I mean I think it's a cool
idea I just don't think it's the the way
you want to start investing I think that
you're a smart guy you've got a good
income and I would just love to see you
pay off this debt I would love to see
you stack up you know a nice emergency
fund and here in in the next year I'd
love to see you start putting 15 away in
a Roth IRA in your 401K with your job
and really start building real wealth
you're going to see a a far better
return on that investment uh than the
the the mingle app and um
hey
um Brad let me can I throw one more
thing at you real quick
yes
um when you're the guy who's made it
and in the neighborhood and with your
family
and you're making eighty thousand
dollars and people see you driving a six
thousand dollar car
they're gonna let you have it they're
gonna clown on you they're gonna make
fun of you they're gonna give you the
business and I just want to tell you I
had a number one best-selling book in
the United States On The Wall Street
Journal list
and I had a nice house with my wife and
I got a place for my kids to live
and from almost all of that time I was
driving a 2012
car with almost a truck with almost 200
000 miles on it
a depreciating asset doesn't Define you
okay
is that cool okay your relationships
dude you very much Dr John delone thank
you very much Jade I appreciate you if
I'm gonna take advice and I it's great
I'm definitely got the app and save as
much as I can she's like he's like guys
stop railing on me hey I love it oh hey
we do love you we're so so proud of you
man you've done some amazing amazing
things I wish I want you to get taken
advantage of and uh Christians can meet
at their local church I think that
sounds like a great idea good job Brad
I'm proud of that guy I want to thank
everyone buddy in the booth even Ben
especially Jenna I don't think you
America for listening to the show great
job Jade love hanging out and thank you
America
be kind to one another pay off your
debts and we'll see you soon this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]